Shauna is in Michigan Shauna how are you
I'm doing well how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's up okay so I just
recently with my husband decided to
listen to some of your principles that
are tried and true we have gotten our
thousand dollars in our savings account
and we're starting to work on our debt
snowball and I find myself quite
overwhelmed so my background I'm
actually a physician and I paid for
myself to get through my undergrad in
medical school and at that point not
blaming it on anyone but didn't get
great advice was kind of told you know
take out the loans you need money to
live and you're going to make enough
money one day you'll be able to pay
these off
well I'm learning now that I've been out
for five years but that's not
necessarily a case and I have two
hundred and ninety seven thousand
dollars in just my student loan debt and
you just lived on that yeah well it
started out at about 200 and over the
years our deferment through residency
it's grown you're an MD for four five
years yeah what do you make about three
hundred thousand dollars a year did you
say three hundred thousand yeah okay so
why have you not paid your loans off um
I don't know
so we're also building a house which we
started that prior boiler I know well my
dad died unexpectedly about a year and a
half ago and he was really young and it
wasn't really a plan for me to kind of
take over responsibility for my mom but
that's what happened sorry okay
why are you having to take over your mom
she can't take care of herself
she she's retired and he has some
rheumatological disorders and has some
issues with movement she's not to the
point where like she needs a caretaker
but we made a decision that we wanted to
have her moving with us because we want
somebody to be looking out for her and
we looked for a home where she could
live with us that had a mother-in-law
suite and we couldn't find anything with
the first level like mother-in-law suite
they were in before the house was
completed it will be completed enjoy
okay
and what did it cost $800,000 for a
mother-in-law suite and we're building a
brand new house so we're going to be
selling our current house and we're
building a house that okay and what will
your car home bring probably about 350
does it paid for no course not what do
you owe on it around 200 so you're
barely gonna get out of it right so
you're taking out an 800,000 on our
mortgage right for a mother-in-law okay
or so for $600,000 I think we could have
found another way to take care of your
mother all right okay does your husband
work outside the home he does good what
does he make mmm he makes about forty to
fifty thousand a year okay so you have a
three hundred and fifty thousand dollar
income with an eight hundred thousand
dollar mortgage and two hundred and
ninety seven thousand dollars in student
loan debt did I get all that right war
that's when the smoke clears okay now
you have to decide if you're going to
continue doing these things that aren't
working if I was your patient and I was
behaving this way you would box my ears
you would say Dave if you keep this up
you're going to kill yourself if I was
your patient and I was doing something
contrary to every possible medical
solution correct Oh
Dave if you keep eating chocolate chips
by the bushel you're going to kill
yourself
Dave if you keep whatever it is right if
you meet patients that are misbehaving
in the care of themselves and if they
continue on that you can look at them
and say you're going to kill yourself
can't you
yep that's what I that's the
conversation I'm having with you can you
feel it what you have to stop you make
plenty of money and you guys completely
misbehave with it and so you need to
stop buying stuff and get on a beans and
rice rice and beans scorched earth
budget you are not a doctor you are a
broke doctor you are 1 over 1 million
dollars in debt yeah good news is you
got a really big shovel and as soon as
your brain wraps itself around what you
have to do to clean this mess up you're
gonna mathematically be able to clean it
up really quickly
but it is so far from the way you've
been living for the most of your life
that it's you're gonna have to
completely retrain your method of
thinking aren't you yeah you're going to
be extremely frugal extremely
intentional and thoughtful with every
penny and there is nothing else is gonna
be bought I don't want to hear any other
rationalizations in your life about
buying something ever again you guys
have got to stop
you should have been rid of the student
loan debt and of course you shouldn't
have built this house these are two I
mean you should you know easily with
$350,000 of income if you just figured
out something for your mom and stayed in
that house for a little while we could
have cleaned this up really fast as it
is this house is gonna slow it down some
but I still think you can do it I know
you can do it mathematically but you and
your husband need to sit down and say
okay we've been sleepwalking through
this like we're a couple of zombies and
we're gonna have to actually get our
hands around this make every one of
these dollars behave we're gonna
download the every dollar app get in
Financial Peace University we're going
to make every one of these dollars
behave because $100,000 a year out of
your income will clean this up pretty
quick